it's a routine part of many parents take
the school run but for Jamie a mo
picking her son up comes with a
particular sense of relief she's a
survivor of the 1999 Columbine High
School shooting every day the mother of
three waits for this moment when her
children SAT back together at home
watching her as a parent you'd have no
idea that she's still dealing with the
trauma of what happened at her high
school that day being in the auditorium
in and listening to what sounded like
were under some kind of attack and it
was that moment of are they coming in
here how long is this gonna go on for
who's doing this
all of those questions started popping
into my head and yeah I started to
realize that something really horrific
ly bad was happening
20 years later Jamie still haunted by
the shooting and its aftermath I
remember walking with a friend she was
waiting to hear from her brother um but
he was one of the ones that no one ever
heard from him gets he was killed in the
library and I always wished that I had
done something besides try to lighten
the mood because their members were
walking I was trying to I could make her
smile because they knew she was worried
um but in hindsight I would I wish I
just wish you know you don't you didn't
know I didn't think it could possibly
there was no way like her brother was
gonna be fine everyone I knew was gonna
be fine at just 15 Jaime had never heard
of post-traumatic stress disorder I
didn't tell anyone that I was feeling
really any kind of way I just pretended
like everything was fine I continued to
pretend that everything was fine how are
you actually feeling terrible you know
you didn't we understand PTSD from a
combat perspective but I feel like
people don't understand that there are
hundreds and thousands of kids over
250,000 kids just since Columbine and
have had a shooting in their school
faith
only children could one day be affected
has led Jamie to campaign for tougher
gun laws this way she was invited by her
Congress representative Madeline Dean as
a guest at president Trump's State of
the Union address
Jamie hoped the president would tackle
the issue of gun violence in schools she
was left disappointed it was offensive
in a way because he knows it's a problem
there's no reason why we can't reinstate
the assault weapons ban there's been
action before we can take action again
and I think we need to 40,000 people a
year are dying because of something it's
guns and it's time that we tackle it
from a legislative approach we can do
the proactive things with mental health
and we can educate the children and try
to create that change of culture but
that takes time
legislation we can do now in the
meantime Jamie holds her children tight
and hopes that they will never have to
face the turmoil she's experienced over
the past two decades here one two three
one Johnny now from San Diego California
is dr. Reed Malloy he's a forensic
psychologist specializing in psychopathy
mental disorders and targeted violence
and he's worked as a consultant for the
FBI for the past 18 years as well dr.
Malloy thank you very much for joining
us the Columbine school shooting this
was two decades ago and yet its
influence has lasted all the way until
today why is that I think the Columbine
event the mass murder that occurred in
Colorado and now 20 years ago really
became a very momentous event in the
history of criminal in the United States
and has been has fostered a number of
copycat cases since then there have been
upwards of 80 different of individuals
over the past 20 years that
have either attempted to mount an attack
or have succeeded in doing that where
they have said that they were directly
inspired by the events at Columbine it
really became a watershed event in
American criminality you know I was
actually in high school in the US when
the Columbine shooting took place I mean
I remember how how shocking that event
was what effect do you think it's had
perhaps on that generation of students
and also on the country as a whole I
think it is I think it's had a huge
effect on the younger generation and I
think one of the markers for that is
what happened following the Parkland
attacks last year where there is really
an upsurge of of young Americans very
interested in changing the access the
very easy access to high-powered weapons
in the United States which still is a
huge problem but this younger generation
really grew up with Columbine as an
event in the recent history if not prior
to when they were born and in a sense it
normalized that school attacks could
happen anytime anywhere although the
reality is that school attacks are still
a very very infrequent in the United
States despite the press coverage of
such attacks nevertheless of course
these are horrible events and I think
the younger generation as demographics
in the United States shift toward a
younger population we're going to see
quite of substantial changes in various
ways that can keep people safer in the
United States now you mentioned of
course unfortunately since Columbine
there have been dozens more mass school
shootings since that time in 1999 and
and as you said many of these
perpetrators actually did idolize the
shooters that were involved in that
shooting in Columbine now how did these
two students essentially become cult
figures for other gunmen now that's an
excellent question that I don't have an
easy answer for I think part of it was
that what they did was very unique at
the time that they would mount an attack
such as this using both firearms as well
as
tempting to use bombs at the school to
actually create an event that was just
as catastrophic as an event that had
happened four years earlier almost on
the same date which was the Oklahoma
City bombing by Timothy McVeigh on April
19th 1995 and part of their plan was in
a sense to do the Oklahoma City bombing
one better and typically that's what we
see in these young perpetrators is they
will follow very closely individuals
that have preceded them and have carried
out these acts of violence and they both
admire them but then also they want to
do them one better and one of the
dynamics that we're seeing in these
cases is that the way that they do this
one better is to try to have more
casualties as well as to do something
innovative and at the time of Columbine
of both the of the innovation and the
casualties and the location of the
shootings major made a huge impression
it horrified of course most people but
for some particularly adolescents and
young adults who felt very
disenfranchised who felt not a part of
the fabric of their of their school or
their community this became in a sense
and an antihero identification and they
were drawn to these figures wanting to
be like them wanting to make a mark that
otherwise they were not making in their
own lives that footage of of Columbine
of the students streaming out of the
school that was played on repeat on news
stations in the US for hours for four
days now for decades now what about now
in terms of the advent of social media
the invention of live streaming video
has that's now changed things in in
terms of these sorts of mass shootings
yeah I think one of the things that's
done is its accelerated these cases
particularly over the past eight to ten
years and there's good data on that from
both FBI studies as well as from a study
that Harvard Public Health did
concerning the this uptick in numbers of
cases so social media really in a sense
becomes an accelerant it becomes a
vector that can carry this in fact
this contagion into other into other
young minds and I think that there also
is now a much greater awareness of the
impact of social media and the
commercial media coverage of these
events and there's been we think
substantial changes in that by the media
for instance the the photo of the
perpetrator is not published as widely
as they used to be they're not they're
not shown in some element where they're
posing with their weapons or with some
kind of camouflage outfit that sort of
glorifies they're a pseudo commando a
presentation and then all three not
clean the loops of the video loops
played over and over again one of the
striking examples of this is what
happened in Christchurch New Zealand
just within the past month we did not
see in the worldwide commercial media
the videotaping the live-streaming of
the massacre that had occurred then and
you see actually you saw a very muted
response to the perpetrator himself and
so I think we're saying some seeing some
important changes dr. Reid Malloy
forensic psychologist specializing in
mental disorders and targeted violence
thank you so much for joining us thank
you thank you very much